c'est une affaire qui a fait beaucoup de
bruit ce week-end celle de l'agression
du maire de la ville de saint-andré au
nord-est de l'île de la réunion par des
candidats de télé réalité
alors que le tournage pour la nouvelle
saison des anges de la télé réalité
diffusée sur nrj 12 était sur le point
de débuter l'impensable s'est produit
j'ai vu des types très bon hockey
tout commence dans le restaurant de
l'hôtel le créolia alors que joé bédier
le maire en question est attablé avec sa
famille en train de déjeuner à côté de
candidats de l'émission un membre de la
production vient prendre à partie le
maire de la ville
l'accusant d'avoir pris des photos d'eux
avec son téléphone portable très vite le
ton monte
et s'il croit d'abord à une blague les
candidats insistent pour voir les
téléphones portables de tous les membres
de sa famille
refus qui aurait mis hors d'eux les
candidats à ce jour trois personnes ont
été interpellées par les forces de
l'ordre dont le coût de pkr données
houda qui a été immédiatement exclue du
tournage pour des raisons de sécurité
sous la pression des locaux
l'équipe du tournage aurait même décidé
de quitter l'île alors à clés sont des
mères par des candidats des anges
la production était le coupable c'est
vrai que il ya eu cette affaire
incroyable
merci m ben sahar d'être avec nous vous
êtes à boca au barreau de paris vous
êtes l'avocat du maire donc qui a été
agressé à la réunion m ben ça pour
représenter joé bédier
dans quel état est aujourd'hui votre
client je crois qu'on peut dire qu'il
est sous le choc les images parlent
d'elles-mêmes l'agression qu'il a subie
a été d'une infinie violence d'abord une
infinie violences par son caractère
arbitraire mais aussi par la lâcheté du
mode opératoire des agresseurs et il ya
une dernière infinie violence que
j'aimerais vous présenter c'est
qu'évidemment cet homme-là a été
agressée mais sa femme et ses fils ont
également été sous ses yeux
c'est ça et vous connaissez tous le
monde peut imaginer ici la souffrance
qui est celle d'un homme qui voit sa
femme et ses filles agressées sous ses
yeux par trois individus qui ont
évidemment agi d'une manière
particulièrement mais véhémente et
particulièrement lâche alors qu'est ce
qui se serait passé selon votre client
alors écoutez mon client était en train
de déjeuner tranquillement dans un
restaurant il a été pris à partie par
ces individus qui ont demandé de ranger
son téléphone évidemment il n'avait pas
sorti faux contextualiser jouer bédié à
65 ans c'est pas un aficionado des anges
de la télé réalité
il ignore tout en réalité de cette
émission évidemment il a dit que c'était
son droit d'avoir son téléphone monsieur
à quoi une ruelle coût est suivie
il est tué absolument tout de suite vous
verrez que les images que l'on peut voir
de cette agression parle d'elle-même
elle est d'une infinie violence c'est
vrai que on a vu ces images vous les
avez vus également chez vous c'est vrai
que c'est très très très très très
violent il est dit qu'une personne de la
production aurait été très agressive
envers le maire et sa famille il est en
train de fêter l'anniversaire de sa
fille je croyais en se restaurant
absolument et puis encore plus que les
violences et aussi la lâcheté du mode
opératoire on s'en prend à deux femmes
lorsqu'elles sont au sol ils sont à
trois enfin c'est vraiment d'une lâcheté
inouïe ça me rappel vous connaissez ou
pas un mot de victor hugo qui est très
juste et qui sera vraiment les décrire
c'est à dire que il ya certaines
personnes qui observent les règles de
l'honneur comme d'autres regarde les
étoiles de très loin voilà on a fait
c'est nous des lâches des gens sans
honneur et qui s'en sont pris à des
femmes dans un restaurant c'est
évidemment inadmissible et c'est la
raison pour laquelle mon client s'est
constituée partie civile et ira au bout
de la procédure judiciaire pour obtenir
réparation de son préjudice d'accord
alors aujourd'hui paraît qu'il est
extrêmement choquée devait venir ce soir
d'ailleurs il va être là en feuilletant
et il est encore très très très choqués
de ce qui s'est passé
il a préféré il est pas en état de
parler mais ce qui est vrai c'est qu'il
a préféré envoyer son avocat parce qu'il
est épuisé parce qu'en réalité il est
sous le choc et aussi parce qu'il ne
souhaite pas s'exprimer en tant que
maire local sur ces faits il s'est déjà
longuement exprimé dans la presse locale
s'agissant du national il a préféré
naturellement et légitimement envoyé son
avocat ce j'aimerais vous dire quand
même il ya quelque chose qui choque
aussi c'est la manière dont se défendre
ces individus parce qu'on a vu sur les
réseaux sociaux un certain nombre de
justification qui sont inadmissibles
on nous dit que le maire n'avait pas
avoir son téléphone on nous dit qu'il
n'avait pas aller au restaurant avec sa
fille tout ça évidemment c'est
inacceptable et ce système de défense
est honteux en réalité on aurait attendu
des excuses
un mot pour dire par pour demander
pardon un mot de regret il faut croire
que pour certains l'île de la réunion
est une zone de non droit et ça c'est
inadmissible à la loi doit s'appliquer
de la même manière sur tout le
territoire de la république
alors là les candidats bien sûr on sait
bon voilà ils sont celles à risque
c'est la production à ce qu'elle vous
avez écrit un mot qu'est-ce que vous
c'est ce que t as qu elle s'est excusée
la production d'émissions à écouter on
n'a pas sollicité des excuses de la part
de la production maintenant je crois que
la responsabilité vous le savez elle est
individuelle
il faudrait pas déresponsabiliser
sectionné autres qui contre les
personnes contre la production mais la
responsabilité pénale encore
une fois et personnel ce soir des faits
de violence et seulement les auteurs de
violences pourront être mis en cause
la production a peut-être réalisé une
erreur de casting ça je sais pas c'est
peut-être subjectif toujours est il
qu'elle n'est pas complice ni auteurs de
cette action au pénal
c'est seulement les trois fonctionnaires
elle est comme ils auraient dû revoir
quand même leur casting la production la
grosse équipe justement parce que en
2010 y est ils sont quand même coutu
coutumier du fait le couple puisqu'ils
ont été condamnés pour violences par le
tribunal correctionnel à un vignon pour
les mêmes faits ils ont agressé deux
jeunes femmes qui étaient fans du couple
ricardo aurait cogné la tête de la femme
contre une table et ils ont été
condamnés par la justice donc à ce
moment-là ce vieux ils disent on va pas
voilà maître de violence dans le casting
et après ils mettent neruda et ricardo
donc là je trouve ça pas normal que la
production les maître d'anglais alors je
vais vous dire c'est vrai que bon la
plupart des gens de télé réalité en plus
c'est des gens plutôt sympa me rejoindre
les play-offs un départ plutôt très cool
dre sympa mais c'est vrai que là ça a
été un gros gros gros dérapage déjà que
les anges de la télé réalité c'était
franchement c'était mort là je pense mot
nicolas cc c'est cuit mais se sert de la
cuy mais la question là c'est ce qu'on a
vu les images à la vidéo c'était le cas
hier
c'est d'une violence inouïe la la c'est
ce qu'on voit là de quoi non mais c'est
effroyable
j'ai honte de la télévision quand je
vois ça parce que je me dis que laisser
des gens comme ça à la télévision qu'ils
peuvent qui peuvent avoir ce genre de
comportement à l'extérieur pour moi
c'est honteux ont ils parlent de gens de
65 ans mais un maire d'une ville avec sa
femme sa fille je salue violents ce qui
nous attend qu'il soit pas là je pense
sincèrement que nrj12 devrait annuler
les vols annulés il faut annuler un
clairon plus mal à m'arrêter voulu
arrêter la barque drop mais oui je
réalisation c'est tout ce que je déteste
laden de la télé réalité c'est à dire
c'est l'écrit mystery sort de deux pour
pardon de ne pas culture racaille comme
ça c'est juste insupportable et en plus
enfin voilà ce que je lui dirai ce qu'il
était alcoolisé ce qu'ils avaient des
substances illicites
ce dossier m'a dit oui m de ce qu'on
sait on a un petit peu enquêter sur la
ferme d'arrêté qui se d alcool manet et
peut-être
l'ampleur sous l'emprise de soupe et de
stupéfiants ce que c'est vrai ou pas
sont des choses qui sont pas exclues
exclu le dossier d'enquêté secret mais
vous ignorez pas qu'il ya trois
circonstances aggravantes qui peuvent
être réunies dans cette affaire d'abord
ce sont des violences qui sont faites en
réunion ensuite ce sont des violences
qui sont faites sur un dépositaire de
l'autorité publique le maire et c'est
certainement aussi des violences sous
l'emprise d'un état alcoolique ou sous
l'emprise de stupéfiants il faut savoir
qu'en france le fait d'être sous cet
état là c'est une circonstance
aggravante ça va pas l'être dédouaner de
leurs responsabilités
tout au contraire alors on va voir le
maire du village
j'aurais bd courroye qui on voit là on
envoie tout notre ami on espère que le
rallye mais pour sa famille surtout
regarder il nous explique ce qui s'est
passé également été littéralement plaqué
au sol
j'ai plus des 10 d'une violence inouïe
par trois types très baraqué
mes enfants ont été menacés et mes
petits enfants toujours
alors je vous parle en état de choc ont
fui la scène de violence on était assis
tranquillement les hommes gaïa où on est
sans défense et ils nous ont attaqués
franchement avec vous pensez qu'il faut
presque ce qu'ils savaient que c'était
le maire alors sa seule enquête nous le
dira c'est pas exclu toujours est il que
qu'il n'en qu'ils en aient connaissance
ou non ça ne retire rien à la gravité de
les faire jouer bédié c'est un individu
exemplaires la faute en clair c'est un
élu local remarquable appréciez vous
avez vu qu'il ya un vent de soutien
exactement exceptionnelle en parler un
instant vous allez voir ce qui s'est
passé et eu un soulèvement incroyable et
ils ont été ils vont ils vont ils vont
dégager de la réunion puisqu'ils vont
annuler le tournage et ils vont partir
de la réunion toutes les équipes de
production et les candidats c'est ça
mais c'est à dire que le comportement
qui a été leur montrent un tel mépris
pour ce qu'est l'île de la réunion qu
effectivement leur présence n'est
peut-être plus souhaité mais alors
regardez ce que dit le maire aussi
puisqu'il explique que ces personnes
étaient un petit peu bizarre pour lui
donner une dame qui se ramène à notre
table il semblerait que avant noël était
passé sur d'autres tables pour agresser
d'autres personnes et à ma table quand
elle se ramène elle fait ouais voilà
vous avez pris des photos ce n'est pas
normal
montrez à vos appareils enfin bref elles
un délire elle était hystérique
hystérique
c'est pour ça que moi je demande à ce
qu'on nous contrôle pour voir si on n'a
pas de la drogue dans notre camp et on
contrôle ces gens là alors guillaume
vous parlez de la chaîne mais pardon la
chaîne n'a rien à voir là dedans
ressurgit do this may la chaîne ils ont
rien à voir le diffuseur ils sont bien
sûr fusée géante et hammerson de la
chaîne sur le tronc et les pauvres ces
deux teams et la production était le
coupable oui c'est pas mon avis et
juridique c'est comme ça quand vous
produisez une mission car oui un
incident sur le tournage c'est vous qui
est coupable
d'ailleurs c'est la production qui va
payer tous les dégâts qui sont ces six
d'érable alors ça sonnait bien
alors j'ai quelques chiffres le coût
d'un épisode des anges regard des 60000
euros par épisode y avait 60 épisodes
qui étaient prévus dont on imagine le
chiffre navire le manque à gagner
les billets d'avion 50 personnes sur
place soit 840 milles euros
trente mille euros par jour minimum pour
les équipes de production cent cinquante
mille euros par mois pour la maison donc
à voir si le propriétaire leurs frais
une ristourne aux pas suite à leur
départ je crois mais candidats dans leur
gueule candidats ils sont payés jusqu'à
1000 euros par jour pour ceux qui sont
le mieux payé est évidemment il est hors
de question que la chaîne rembourse 1
euro de 1 bien sûr fait des gars c'est
pas leurs mots clés pour l'assurance ils
sont en train de voir mais à mon avis
c'est très chaud pour faire passer ça en
assurance donc les pertes peuvent aller
jusqu'à cinq cent mille euros pour cet
incident ce qui est quand même énorme
alors on va tous russes pour ceux qui
nous rejoignent regardez encore ces
images d'une violence inouïe
regardez
[Applaudissements]
il ya des nanas clé des filles aussi
qu'il ya deux reprises et donc le maire
et sa famille aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent
qu'est ce qu'ils risquent ce qui là que
peut il apporter plein d'autres clients
et alors j'ai cru comprendre que pour au
moins deux des trois agresseurs il y
avait déjà un casier judiciaire fourni
et notamment fourni d'infraction de même
nature
tout me laisse penser que des sanctions
pénales importante pourrait être prise
alors évidemment du côté du maire nous
on souhaite pas de détention
d'incarcération n'est pas du tout dans
une optique de surenchère de violence de
répression nous tout ce qu'on veut c'est
qu'il y ait une déclaration publicité
pour on comprenne bien que la loi est
identique partout et on aide respar
impunément y compris l île de la réunion
raymond moi ce qui me choque là dedans
c'est que voilà la chaîne oui papa pas
responsables mais mais les gens qui
étaient dans la production quand même tu
es dans un hôtel c'est un lieu public un
hôtel il ya des gens qui déjeunent s'il
ya des gens en vacances on a vu des
enfants on a vu des bébés dans les bras
des parents qui sauf l'image qu'ils ont
ces enfants gâtés la de la télé réalité
l'esprit se croisent sur un an mais je
vais vous dire il croit qu'on va les
ventes renouer on dit la vérité
si benjamin tu me lis j'écris je suis
producteur d'une émission est ce que ça
arrive ça maintenant le vrai problème
c'est que alors je parle et quand tu te
mets un écart pas ce que tu veux pas
être en photo mais se prennent pour qui
pour quoi vous devez juste mais c'est
comme si ce temps demain on va te
prendre vraiment dans un restaurant je
devais te taper le mur est bon on est là
on est tous content on fait de l'aide de
l'antenne et on sonne à tout signé une
clause dans ce sens où nous avons doit
se tenir dans mon public il ya des jours
on doit passer on a sûrement mal par
l'excellent lui ne perd plus haut jamais
atteint non mais vraiment je ne veux pas
parler comme un vieux mais aller à une
époque il ya quelques années quand on
faisait un casting de télé réalité et
quand on veut ou à la hong kong a cédé
des candidats ont mené une enquête
vous voyez qu'il était location alors
lors quasi rond français sur l'or là on
attend que ça arrive hélas non juste un
truc et je dis aux téléspectateurs
qu'ils vont comprendre c'était pas les
mêmes budgets
là ils chérissent de demander à caser le
faire faire faire voir le psy excusez
moi c'est pas un budget qu'ils entendent
à le faire sur instagram de meute des
photos de dire aux gens à acheter les
produits qu'on vous vend s'est ouvert
les veines
vers les enfants gâtés c'est pas
entendable de faire le beau sur
installer de dire après mais par contre
quand je suis au restaurant me prenez
pas en photo comprenant photos faites
par les gens l'achètent pernikoff ne
veut dire deux choses je sais qu'il va
pas vous plaire je pense d'abord ça
c'est pas de la témérité pour moi c'est
la télé trash donc surtout une chose
importante c'est vous savez qu'il ya eu
un monsieur qui a fait de la peine this
pendant des années pendant quinze ans de
l'attraper donnan tremayne voyez moi je
pense que c'est les limites de ce genre
de programme c'est carrément donné le
mec qui s'est retrouvé président de la
république pendant cinq ans mais lui il
est toujours une télé réalité
même aujourd'hui à la minute où je vous
parle donc un moment donné je construis
effectivement je le compare pas aux
anges
mais ce que je veux vous dire c'est qu'à
un moment donné il ya une limite à cette
télé oui voilà c'est tout et donc il
faut garder le contrôle des choses mais
alors oui j'aurais laissé une telle
effectivement et moi j'ai toujours dit
s'y est même souvent contre mes
camarades est contre moi d'ailleurs
aussi il ya une culture de la violence
il ya une culture de la baston tous les
rapports entre les hommes et les femmes
dans cette danse est télé réalité ils se
parlent mal il ya des insultes
il ya des injures on se trompe on se
trompe pas c'est insupportable
d'abord pour les rapports hommes femmes
pour les rapports entre les humains tout
court est en fait moi je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec nicolas c'est à dire
que effectivement aujourd'hui dans une
sorte de dérive et je pense que ils sont
en fait les et ils veulent le bad buzz
alors oui ils sont quelques-uns goods
il veut juste qu'on parle de serre grêle
des plus tactique ils s'en foutent
wen sont totalement film et isabelle
café les anges de la mémé réalité oui
non moi je suis désolé c'est la faillite
de tout le monde y compris de celui qui
regarde parce que moi je me souviens
avoir vu cette émission avec des jeunes
disaient ouais aujourd'hui ça clashe pas
assez alors dans des années et des
années on a posé des alizés alesi
pouvoir défendre leur bourrer la gueule
donc allez-y à les y est pour moi tout
le monde est coupable
la production je suis désolé mais
juridiquement l'a jamais le diffuseur
est aussi responsable de ce qui arrive
dans une introduction racing pas
d'accord comme ça
sur la mise à l'enquêté qu'un problème
et excellence m
oui c'est lui qui est responsable aussi
je vais vous dire ces images a même font
même honte moi j'ai eu ma blessure pour
nous les français la métropole avec nos
amis français
la réunion qui sont des gens charmants
accueillant je suis sûr que c'est un
bonheur pour les gens de l'île de la
réunion de les avoir en plus et ils
auront gâché la fête les aurois
taravello ont gâché la fête je suis
décidé à faire acquis voilà c'est ça oui
à terre après sept années chez les trucs
parce que le diable est juste je
comprends l'image de la télé réalité
tout ça ils sont pas tous comme ça non à
dubaï ma part très mal en ce moment avec
la télé on regarde les émissions quand
les jeunes regardent les photos ça ils
sont très drôles ils sont marrant ils
sont pas tous bien sûr est très violent
à gaza un amour voilà julien annonce il
est méchant juste mettre m ben ça qu'est
ce qui va se passer maintenant ça va
être quoi la suite elle aurait eu
lankais devait suivre son cours et
l'issue de laquelle le procureur de la
république pourra décider d'un renvoi
devant le tribunal correctionnel ou d'un
classement sans suite cette deuxième
hypothèse étant évidemment exclu tous
les moyens juridiques seront employées
en tout cas du côté de joël bêty pour
conclure a effectivement un renvoi
devant le tribunal ait une sanction
pénale ainsi qu'une réparation civile
alors moi je vous dis ce que j'ai comme
un faux entre voilà à prendre avec des
pincettes mais ce que dirait la
production c'est que le leur version
c'est qu'il ya une personne de la
production qui est allé voir le maire et
sa femme et que sa femme l'aurait
agressée agressé cette personne d'un
produit dont vous avez entendu parler de
cette version
voilà les queues en fait les les gars
sont donc des angles l'aurait défendu
cette personne la production et ce
serait parti donc en cacahuète série de
série alors c'est évident et magasins
les chinois qui répond pour sa part on
va la vendre la paire cesse de se
désoler secoué je vous en prie la
personne de la production pourquoi les
partis voir la femme du maire parce
qu'il prenait des photos si t'es pas
content prennent en photo reste chez toi
prenez des prix
savamment pourrait apporter un peu de
gens il faut noter que cette version
elle est corroboré par rien elle est
complètement fantasmatique et lesquels
au mieux il y en a où il ya aucun témoin
n'a aucune vidéo rien ne concorde dans
ses déclarations et son fantasme pour
rire pourrait dire en un mot elles sont
mensongères je vous disais tout à
l'heure que je trouvais les lignes de
défense de ces candidats un peu
décevante
effectivement un mot un peu digne un mot
d'excusé suffirait vous allez dire que
je fais le dictionnaire des citations
mais il ya un mot de jean de la bruyère
qui est très juste là dessus c'est que
je dormais pardon mais c'est d'une borne
à l'isère la bruyère grande misère ne
pas assez d'intelligence pour critère
nièce et d'esprit pour dire bien les
choses voilà ces gens là pourrait aussi
prendre le temps de la réflexion et
essayer de donner un mode excuses
d'abord pour jouer bédié ensuite pour ça
fait les gens de la guérilla juridique
sur l'île de la réunion
adil rami qui nous écrit qui dit j'ai
l'impression que peu partout il ya
beaucoup de français hors france c'est
source de problème malheureusement nous
avons parfois une mauvaise mentalité on
est aigri est pas gentil
c'est triste et c'est vrai et j'ai honte
parfois moi j'envoie de la force au
maire et vous sur le plateau mais que
nous voilà il nous embrasser en tout cas
à dire que j'aime fort et c'est vrai je
vous le dit voilà je vous dis la vérité
c'est inadmissible parce que ça nous
fait pas une bonne pub voilà partout
mais bon voilà et les français de la
réunion
tout ce qui a été un lion je vous
disposez une joie est là aujourd'hui il
ya un soulèvement est ce que c'est vrai
qu'ils ont dû quitter leur hôtel parce
que il y avait des réunionnais qui se
sont soulevés et ils ont eu peur pour
l'intégrité physique de ses candidats de
télé réalité est ce que c'est vrai qu'à
production mais c'est ce qu'a dit la
production il paraît qu'ils deux maisons
très ils vont y lisons calfeutrer parce
qu' il allait certainement se faire
attaquer par des personnes qui ont très
mal pris ce qui s'est passé non je crois
qu'il faut savoir raison garder il n'y a
aucun fait de violence qu'on peut
reprocher des réunionnais dans ce
dossier on n'a vu aucun élément en ce
sens je crois que la production essaye
de se dédouaner présenter un climat de
violences réciproques slimane n'existe
pas ce qui est vrai en revanche c'est
qu'ils aient eu un soulèvement de la
part des réunionnais pour soutenir leur
maire et d'ailleurs c'est la plus grande
fierté pour un maire d'avoir le soutien
de ses administrés donc je vais bédié
les remercie solennellement alors il y
aura demain avec mon raphaël pépin qui
sera en droit de réponse voilà puisqu'il
a sa version également des faits est et
de ce qui s'est passé guillaume ya quand
même aujourd'hui un problème autour du
traitement des candidats téléréalité
tiffany l'a dit il ya des exceptions et
à thomas et nabila qui ont fait une
marque et c'est qui qui qui réussissent
bien et aujourd'hui candidat de télé
réalité vous allez 20 ans vous avez
aucun talent vous avez rien
vous gagnez jusqu'à 100000 euros par
mois vous êtes adulé par année mais ça
c'est pour ça qu'ils pètent les plombs
pas d'accord m bah ça pour nos
téléspectateurs jusqu'à ce que vous
aimeriez qu'il y ait comme sanction pour
ses personnels encore une fois on n'est
pas dans une logique de sanction
l'espère rien de mal pour ces individus
là on veut juste que les mots de la
justice résonne et qu'en réalité une
déclaration pulpe et militer
interviennent après sur le quantum de la
peine ça ne vous est complètement on en
est désintéressé nous ce qu'on veut
c'est qu'il soit coupable c'est qu'il y
ait une réparation et que le symbole de
la justice soit rendue
c'étaient les spectateurs japonais aux
publics vous pensez que les anges de la
réalité doivent être annulée purement et
simplement avec l'émission doit
disparaître dit non oui mais non mais
moi j'ai un soucis seront pas condamnés
rien parce que s'attaquer à un élu la
république si vous le faites si
n'importe qui de nous le fait demain on
sera en garde à vue risque vous voulez
dire que les marchés sources et arena
alors d'abord sachez que tout sera fait
pour qu'il soit condamné en bonne et due
forme puisque la partie civile donc
jouer bédié peut en réalité pousser un
procès pénal peut en réalité faire
accélérer les enquêtes donc tout sera
fait en ce sens ont dit qu'ils repartent
aujourd'hui librement il n'est pas dit
qu'il reparte pas sans convocation
devant le tribunal correctionnel il
n'est pas dit qu'elle parte pas avec la
coque le couperet est l'épée de damoclès
d'une enquête qui suit son cours croyez
moi là où ils sont ils doivent pas être
tout à fait tranquille ni serein parce
qu'ils savent que tôt ou tard la
guillotine judiciaire de en réalité du
procès pénal tombera alors regardez les
manifestations devant l'hôtel qui sait
les manifestations qui sont partis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est oui ça va non parce que là il
paraît que voilà il avait peur voilà de
violence là de ce convoi ah oui est ce
que vous pensez qu'il faut arrêter cette
émission wiki fanny non je pense pas il
ne doit pas arrêter l'émission par
contre revoir le cas si vous vous rendez
compte que si moi je peux être au
courant qu'il ya eu des violences le
tribunal correctionnel vous doutez bien
que la production peut le savoir aussi
donc juste ne pas mettre ce genre
d'éléments au casting nicolas pernikoff
personnellement je suis diffuseur de
cette émission je me pose quand même la
question de savoir si la marque ne va
pas abîmer la chaîne n'a pas permis déjà
dit alors je vous parle d'énergie 12 mai
s'est passé nrj c'est une très bonne et
je vous parle d'énergie doué je moi moi
aujourd'hui directeur des programmes de
nrj 12 je me demande si je reconduis une
saison même si ça marche ou ça ne marche
pas des gens et en plus on perd il
arrive non je voudrais le dire c'est
vraiment des gens formidables super
riches la série drôle m parce qu'à
chaque fois qu'on est de culture jamais
ils sont pleins ils sont toujours là
pour nous envoyer des invités il essaie
de faire le maximum parce qu'ils ont peu
de moyens
nrj12 et franchement ils ont mis plein
de trucs en place qui cartonne heures ce
soir ya crime insurer nrj 12 autres qui
cartonne chaque semaine et c'est vrai
que là sa demie à la nouvelle de la
jeune tchèque energy wind energy nous
c'est plus ça fait c'est jean marc
morandini avec des dés des documentaires
des magazines intéressant voilà il ya
d'autres choses très intéressantes sur
nrj12 ya des très bonnes séries
moi je vous dis et là c'est vrai que ça
pollue lâcher oui la drogue prend ses
candidats alors que ces candidats on
sait que nuit par exemple a un casier
judiciaire long comme le bras normal ça
donc ils le savent
la méthode le sait vous ne pensez pas
que la chaîne et on répercute à la
chaîne alors les demandes non vous avez
tant la chaîne la chaîne elle fait fait
confiance à la production d'accord isolé
quand on confie une case et une émission
à la production ont fait confiance à la
production voilà ça chez eux ont
normalement ils ont confiance à la grand
la grosse équipe qui l'a déjà fait
pendant des années mais moi je vous dire
un truc je vais vous dire un truc
géraldine vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
vous croyez quoi je dis aux
téléspectateurs qu'ils nous rejoignent à
21h11 ya eu cette affaire
voilà deux semaines agressés par des
candidats de la télé réalité vous croyez
quoi croyez que dans le casting
ils vont prendre que des mecs ils
retrouvent des mecs qui veulent prendre
des vacances au chaud et doit reprendre
des magasins
oui ils veulent prendre des mecs qui si
l'ex qu'on veut c'est qu'il y ait des
bagarres dans la maison c'est que donc
forcément un moment quand les mecs en
plus ils sont chauffés toute la journée
par la production à un moment même 2
alors qu'ils veulent faire les caïds et
veulent faire les veaux c'est ce qui se
passe souvent voilà on va pas se mentir
il serait donc ça ça c'est aussi et ils
vont pas prendre des personnes un coup
de fans un peu terne et alors moi je dis
que d'abord les enjeux ya beaucoup de
gens qui regardent peut-être que
l'émission alors y'a pas beaucoup donc
et regardent c'est tout à fait 200000
créations mac faudrait peut-être que
l'émission elle doit continuer ça c'est
un autre débat mais regarde je vais
prendre l'exemple avec vous quand vous
partez en laponie quant aux parts à las
vegas quand vous partez avec votre soit
brouillé avec insert ont la peau
d'accord mais quand vous parlez vous
parlez de personnalités vous avez pris
des gens ici qui ont tous fait quelque
chose dans leur vie plus ou moins et qui
ont des personnalités aussi des gens
c'est bien sûr mais quand vous partez en
déplacement en délocalisations il s'en
fout le bordel comme ça mais alors on
n'a pas 20 ans bien sûr on n'a pas 20
ans et ils ont pas 20 ans n'ont même pas
fait c'est quand même des enfants quand
même des enfants gâtés et qu'est ce qui
serait passé s'il y avait eu un truc
comme ça avec quelqu'un de chez nous à
nos ç'aurait été un bavoir questionnant
raffainer voilà mais non répond la part
ça y est on est parfois que je dis la
vérité moi voilà j'ai tort moi il peut
m'arriver
voilà si quelqu'un mais pépé mais avec
un longue date avec un langage me suis
jamais oubliés avec un mandat dans un
restaurant moi moi je m'en rappelle je
me rappelle de rien un truc je vous dis
je vous raconter une histoire
un jour je suis dans un restaurant voilà
dans paris et il ya un mec qui avec sa
meuf et j'entends je sais que des
copains et il dit ça ça me arrête de
regarder le juif
aïe aïe aïe bon alors voilà un quart
d'heure après voilà on sait ça ça a
chauffé le restaurant le restaurant elle
a fait sortir mais voilà c'était pas
fait une émeute n'a pas fait un truc je
suis allé le voir je ne pouvais pas
parler comme ça etc
mais il peut m'arriver mais aussi de
péter un câble mais là en l'occurrence
quand on me demande des photos quand
vous tous vous demandent des photos de
ça c'est le métier s'est dit c'est ça se
voulait pas faire de photos si vous
voulez manger tranquillement au
restaurant ne fait pas ce métier fait
autre chose voilà
et je vous dis et le public c'est ce qui
vous fait vivre c'est ce qui vous c'est
ce qui va mal on ten sirigu regarde pas
le moi je vous le dis souvent en télé et
vous voyez
et je le fais à chaque fois j'ai il
m'arrive très souvent eu voilà
d'insultés de mal parler de gens
puissants de patron de télé de patron
voilà mais il ya un seul et nous on a un
seul et unique patron ici c'est vous
c'est le plein jeudi c'est pas démago ce
que je veux dire c'est juste c'est vrai
au demain vous le dis si on marche plus
et si on fait les audiences de merde
et là je vous le dis vous pouvez être
hyper copain avec le patron allait boire
des verres tous les jours avec lui c'est
inquiétez pas il ira boire des verres
avec vous mais les voilà c'est tout mais
le seul et unique patron en télévision
c'est le public donc ces jeunes au télé
réalité s'ils respectent pas le public
ces chiffres qui font pas carrière et la
première personne et les seuls gens à
respecter dans le métier et je le dis
c'est pour ça que j'ai souvent des
problèmes parce que on dit souvent que
je m'attaque à plein de gens je
m'attaque très souvent beaucoup plus aux
puissants et vous le savez voilà quand
je vais attaquer tf1 quand je m'attaque
à des grosses chaînes quand je m'attaque
à des gros groupes
je m'attaque voilà je préfère mais en
tout cas le public qu'il faut toujours
le respecter et je le respecterai
toujours l'oubli et les si j'ai un
conseil à leur donner
respectez votre public parce que je
pense que ce mère et sa fille il avait
qu'un seul cliffs et de faire des photos
avec vous parce que c'était
l'anniversaire de sa fille et que le mr
et cdh maintien en plus ça va être un
kif pour ma fille voilà de faire des
photos avec ces jeunes qui sont tête
voilà des gens qu'elle aime bien et pour
lesquels ils de la réunion pour les
réunionnais je peux vous dire que
c'était un très bon moment pour eux de
les avoir touchés ils ont tout gâché
voilà je le dis à prendre ils vont peu
gâchée oui m au barça non mais c'est
pire que ça c'est à dire qu'en fait ni
le maire ni ni ses films même sa femme
et vous savez qui étaient ces abus et
personne n'a voulu prendre de photos
avaient encore c'est à dire qu'on est
dans une telle menace mégalomanie de
leur part dans les gyms n importe quelle
personne dans ce restaurant sous été
photographiée mais que c'est évidemment
pas le cas juste pour recentrer le débat
alors y'a rien mercereau du figaro qui
est un très bon journaliste qui me dit
quand même une énergie nous tu valides
les castings mais bon sa série casting
oui mais non seulement messagerie là
dessus il faut pas il faut recentrer le
débat le sujet des casiers judiciaires
dans les castings ne doit pas exister
on a tous eu droit à l'erreur qu'un
individu ait une petite tâche sur son
parcours sa ne l'empêchent pas de
participer à une émission il faut pas
stigmatiser les individus au seul
prétexte qu'ils ont eu un regard sur
judas le droit de faire une et on a le
droit à l'erreur et nous maintenant en
revanche qui est plus certain c'est
qu'il faut effectivement lorsqu'il ya
des comportements de cette nature à
porter une sanction de la part de
l'émission aussi ou de la production
nous on attendrait peut-être un mot
excuses de leur part c'est le soin de la
production de la chaîne qui importe mais
le principe d'un modèle adapté aux
abeilles quittent ils n'ont pas fait de
mots d'excusé mais combien ce stade et
je pense que c'est plus que souhaitait
se serait en fait la moindre des dignité
ou des fadas dois m'excuser pour
l'instant puisque pour la production
c'est le maire qui s'est mal comporté
oui enfin je crois que ce débat est déjà
dépassées on voit bien d'abord de la
manière dont l'enquêté se déroule mais
aussi de la réaction des réunionnais et
surtout de la vidéo que vous avez
présenté que le mauvais comportement ne
vient pas du maire mais des candidats et
moi et moi tu veux dire énergie grâce à
une chaîne vraiment je vous dis c'est
des gens géniaux
voilà qui travaillent dans cette chaîne
et je suis persuadé vous verrez je suis
persuadé qu nrj12 à mon avis ils vont
lever le pied sur les anges de la télé
réalité et moi je vous dis je pense
qu'on n'est pas prêt de le voir à
l'antenne ni de les revoir à l'antenne
cette émission après c'est mon avis je
ne sais pas ce qui va se passer on va
voir ce qu'on va voir le sondage tient
des téléspectateurs qu'est ce qu'ils
disent oui à 84% faut-il arrêter les
anges non 16% en tout cas merci m
d'avoir été avec nous